hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar advances in celiac disease
testing from method validation to
serological diagnosis
i am antonina salcido of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by bio-rad laboratories
to learn more please visit biorad.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
lucia cepaciovelli clinical biochemist
at the hospital for sick children and dr
jane dickerson medical director at the
chemistry lab at seattle children's
hospital
dr
sepia chevelli and dr dickerson you may
now begin your presentations
thank you for the introduction
our learning objectives for today are to
describe the analytical methods for
celiac disease serology used in clinical
laboratories
and discussed challenges in implementing
a serological diagnosis for celiac
disease
and lastly to describe two
considerations for validating a new
cutoff in an assay
first to begin with a brief introduction
on what is celiac disease it is a
disease of multifactorial causes
including genetic and environmental and
it's characterized by small intestinal
inflammation that is elicited in
response to dietary gluten
in individuals with genetic
predisposition to the disease
gluten is a general name for proteins
found in wheat rye barley and triticale
gluten health food maintain their shape
acting as a glue that holds foods
together and it can be found in many
types of food even ones that would
normally not expect
putin is composed of two protein classes
including glutenins and glydines glydens
are the water soluble component and a
primary toxic component of gluten
containing proline and glutamine reach
peptide sequences ingestion of gluten
leads to generation of harmful gluten
peptides which can induce adaptive and
immune responses in predisposed
individuals
therefore celiac disease is a genetic
autoimmune enteropathy that's caused by
ingestion of gluten peptides
it's a relatively commonly occurring
disease with a global prevalence of
approximately one percent although this
varies dramatically based on the
population and geographic location
celiac disease is largely asymptomatic
although it is associated with a
heterogeneous clinical presentation with
both intestinal and x-ray intestinal
symptoms as shown on the figure on the
right
diarrhea bloating and constipation are
common intestinal symptoms that are
associated with chronic inflammation in
the small bowel mucosa
additionally there could be
malabsorption related symptoms including
poor growth or weight loss reproductive
issues
joint pain skin rashes or mouth sores
therefore it can affect nor a number of
organ systems
celiac disease can be triggered any time
over a person's lifespan and therefore
it can be diagnosed during childhood or
adulthood
and the diagnostic evaluation consists
of serologic tests as well as a small
bowel biopsy
there are a number of at-risk groups
that require periodic screening for
celiac disease
since they have a higher risk of
developing celiac disease and these
groups include those with first-degree
relatives
of those who have a celiac disease
diagnosis a certain autoimmune diseases
such as type 1 diabetics autoimmune
thyroid disease autoimmune liver disease
and juvenile idiopathic arthritis
down syndrome turner syndrome and
williams syndrome as well as iga
deficiency
treatment for celiac disease is lifelong
and involves strict adherence to a
gluten-free diet
the goal of treatment is to remove the
initiator of immune response and down
regulate inflammation
celiac disease diagnosis is confirmed if
in fact the patient responds to a
gluten-free diet with improvements in
clinical symptoms and serologic tests
according to recommendations by a number
of societies including the american
college of gastroenterology
and the european society for pediatric
gastroenterology hepatology and
nutrition serologic tests
play an important role in assessing
dietary adherence and monitoring or
serving as surrogate markers for mucosal
recovery
besides neurology there are a number of
other important lab around parameters to
monitor such as nutritional markers
however this is outside of the scope of
today's presentation
serologic tasks
for celiac disease together with
genotyping for celiac disease risk
alleles hla dq2 and dq8
are part of the
lab tools that we have for non-invasive
evaluation of celiac disease
in terms of serologic tests we have the
tissue transcontaminates iga and mgg
antibodies endomesial iga antibodies and
deomitated wide and iga antibody assays
and it's important to emphasize that
these assays
although serologic tests can be used in
the context of screening for celiac
disease or for monitoring
overall looking at these lists of tests
they have variable clinical utility and
should be used in the appropriate
context and in the correct combination
for optimal patient care
intestinalization
and as dr jane dickerson will talk about
further
although these tests are useful
biopsy often remains as a gold standard
i wanted to discuss a couple of the
tests and additional detail that we
offer in our clinical lab
and this includes the ttga antibodies
and the ema
assay
in terms of ttg iga
antibodies
they're measured using amino acid-based
approaches and there are various kinds
of immunoassay formats available
when we report ttg iga this is reported
as a semi-quantitative value and
arbitrary units that are attributed to
the test
uh we also have a cut off on our report
this is a manufacturer recommended assay
cut off that facilitates the
interpretation of positive or negative
on the report
i wanted to highlight the immunoglobulin
class of this test the iga
so it's important that we're not talking
about ttg igg antibodies ttg iga
antibodies is the most highly sensitive
test for celiac disease screening
and this is this main advantage
and a number of guideline
recommendations recommend using tpg iga
as a primary screening test or first
tier screening test
this test does have several limitations
um
one of them being that false positives
may occur using this test due to various
reasons which are documented in the
literature
another test that i wanted to talk about
is the endomesial iga antibodies or ema
this test is more complex since
the methodology is indirect
immunofluorescence typically using
monkey esophagus tissue as substrate um
therefore serum samples are screened at
a specific screening titer and they can
also be serially diluted in order to
obtain an end point titer which will
give which can give us a
semi-quantitative assessment of
endomesial iga antibody concentrations
at the screening titer we may interpret
the sample as positive or negative
and just to illustrate an example here
you can see an ema positive sample uh
using this monkey esophagus substrate
and it shows a typical honeycomb
immunofluorescence pattern um in the
smooth muscle whereas the epithelium
remains dark
as you can tell the interpretation for
this test it can be quite subjective
and
the method itself is quite labor
intensive and therefore it's associated
with long turnaround times
as a result of this the ema test is not
performed routinely by many clinical
labs in the evaluation of celiac disease
it is strongly dependent on the
local
preference
or ordering preferences
and the local lab protocol
the advantage of the ema test is that it
has the highest specificity for celiac
disease screening with greater than 98
specificity reported and therefore it is
considered as a reference standard or
confirmatory method and in our lab
we screen using the ttg iga assay and
then we confirm
positive samples using the ema assay
therefore we use it as a confirmatory
test
in the evaluation validation and
implementation of such celiac disease
serology tests clinical labs are faced
with several challenges
first we have a wide variety of
analytical methods and analytical
platforms to choose from when setting up
celiac disease serology tests and in the
context of lack of assay standardization
we're seeing highly variable analytical
and clinical test performance
another challenge that clinical labs are
facing is limited access to clinically
well characterized samples with defined
clinical histories that include the
results of biopsy
and even when that's available it's
important to consider the biopsies
themselves are subjective when being
interpreted
and lastly our validation protocols
should account for the heterogeneity in
the clinical spectrum of celiac disease
or the type of samples that arrive to
the clinical lab for celiac disease
evaluation
all of these taken together
translate into the need to analyze
several hundred specimens for a robust
clinical evaluation of a method and this
may not always be feasible or practical
for many clinical labs implementing a
new method
and lastly it's important as part of our
validation and implementation to provide
clinically useful interpretation on the
report however for celiac disease
serology tests this is still a widely
debated topic
and dr jane dickerson
in her study has nicely addressed a lot
of these challenges and she'll talk
about them in more detail
to further highlight the analytical
diversity that we have for celiac
disease serology
this is an example for the variety of
methods available for the tcg iga amino
assay
traditional methods have been
enzyme-linked amino acids but recently
we've seen the emergence of other
analytical platforms that involve or are
based on chemiluminescent amino acid
principle fluorescence enzyme amino acid
and a multiflex bead amino acid
i'll be talking in more detail about the
chemiluminescent amino acid platform and
dr dickerson will be covering the
multiplex bead amino acid platform
in terms of general steps in an amino
acid we have a plate well or
paramagnetic bead that's coated with
antigen to which we apply our serum
sample that contains our antibodies of
interest
this serum
upon addition to the antigen coated
solid phase support is incubated and
washed and then subsequently we add
conjugated anti-human iga antibodies
after another incubation and wash a
substrate is added which results in a
reaction which can be measured as a
change in the absorbance or color
luminescence or fluorescence signal the
signal intensity is proportional to the
antibody concentration in the sample and
therefore the signal can be converted
into a concentration using a calibration
curve or a ratio value
in our lab we use the chemiluminescent
immunoassay platform the anova bioflash
for ttg iga testing
it does have several advantages
this
analytical principle is associated with
a wider dynamic range
and high analytical sensitivity
additionally this method is suitable for
high throughput analysis due to
reduced incubation times and rapid
signal and acquisition
the reagents are stable on board for
several weeks
and also this uh testing platform can be
used as a random access to facilitate
faster turnaround time
this type of a method does have several
limitations
for example we may have low background
levels of emission in the absence of
analytes sometimes and it does have
non-linear plots of response versus
analyte concentration
at this point i wanted to illustrate how
can a method choice impact assay
performance and demonstrate a practical
example from our lab
when we switched our ttg iga method
so prior to the switch we are using the
thermo fischer fabia fluorescent enzyme
amino acid with a cutoff of less than 4
being negative 4 to 10 is weak positive
and greater than 10 units per milliliter
denoting a positive result
subsequently we switched to the innova
bioflash chemiluminescent immunoassay
method
with the different units of measure and
cutoff less than 20 denoted a negative
result 20 to 30 a week positive and
greater than 30
as the
positive interpretation in
chemoluminescent units
an analytical performance validation was
conducted for this assay
with a precision of six to eight percent
and a concordance of 98
with their previous method with a 100
negative concordance and 97
positive
concordance
during this time when the method switch
was made the lab was moved
from the pathology department to the
biochemistry department within their
pediatric lab medicine department
and the test performance was monitored
here you can see long-term performance
monitoring
for the two test methods so
on the x-axis we have the month and on
the y-axis we have the percent
positivity rate for that month
for the fluorescence enzymatic assay
method we had an average positivity rate
of about five percent
although it ranged anywhere from two to
eight percent
after the method switch happened as you
can see there was a dramatic rise in the
positivity rate for the assay
uh with
a significant rise in the average
monthly positivity rate for the
chemiluminescent immunoassay which
generated some questions with regards to
the high frequency of positive flags
to look at this more closely we looked
at average monthly flagging rates for a
two-year period for each of the methods
for the fluorescence enzyme and no assay
we had a 93 negativity rate a 5
positivity rate and a 3 weak positive
rate
for the chemoluminescent amino acid
method we had an 83 negativity rate 13
positivity rate and a 4 week positive
rate
so there has been about two and a half
fold increase in the positivity rate for
the cia method
and this is in the context of no change
in the patient population
a significant rise in the positivity
rate
was of concern so we sought to
investigate this further
and we looked at our concordance with
our confirmatory test the ema test
so for the fluorescence enzyme amino
acid we had a 72
positive concordance so 72 percent of
the ttg iga positive samples were also
positive on ema testing
and 89 of the samples that were negative
on the fluorescence enzyme immunoassay
were also negative on ema testing
for the chemiluminescent amino acid
however we had 56
of the
ptg iga positive samples that were
positive on ema testing therefore
although we're flagging more um during
screening on our confirmatory method
we're able to confirm fewer results
during the method switch a protocol was
implemented where only ttg iga positive
samples underwent ema testing as part of
the confirmation protocol and therefore
we didn't have any negative concordance
data
to summarize the lessons learned and
potential next steps for the validation
and post implementation monitoring i
wanted to highlight that despite the
very good analytical concordance we did
observe variable performance in terms of
their rise in the positivity rate for a
ttg iga assay
and then a decrease in the
proportion of the samples that were
confirmed on ema testing
as a next step it would be important to
conduct a clinical performance
validation with clinically well
characterized samples in order to verify
they
currently use thresholds and cutoffs and
to try to optimize them to either
improve this concordance
or obtain better characterization of
test performance
another important and valuable lesson
was that it would have been
more informative to examine
methodological concordance with a
confirmatory test the ema test for the
ttg ig assay during method validation
however this is not always practical due
to the
labor-intensive nature of the
endometrial antibody test
and then another
important quality assurance parameter to
monitor is to continue looking at our
monthly positive and negative rates for
long-term test performance
thank you for joining us today and for
your attention i'm happy to take
questions at the end but you may also
email me at this email with your
questions or comments i wanted to thank
dr dickerson for working on and
developing this webinar with me and
byron laboratories for sponsoring it as
well as lab roots for hosting it
um and now i'll be passing along to dr
dickerson for her
presentation you
so in this next portion we're going to
discuss
the idea of implementing a biopsy-free
diagnosis for celiac disease
specifically
by evaluating ttg iga
by the bioplex 2200 in a pediatric
population
i'd like to take a minute to just
highlight a few interesting things about
the evolution of celiac serology over
the past several decades we heard a nice
uh introduction of some of these tests
and i won't go go into them in detail
but just kind of point out a few of the
uh
parts that i think are most fascinating
um one that the year is not on this
slide but biopsies became kind of the
mainstay for celiac diagnoses and around
the 1950s
and over the course of the next two
decades um there was a lot of interest
in developing serology and that really
started with mouse-based antibodies
assays that used mouse-based antibodies
for anti-reticuline and gliadin
antibodies and these weren't
particularly sensitive or specific
and have since been completely
replaced by by more modern
testing
however anti-endomesial antibody we we
heard about that um previously
i think we're all we've all we're all
familiar with how it can still be used
that test was introduced
uh in the 70s kind of serendipitously it
was discovered by a group of researchers
who were trying to identify antibodies
from patients who had a particular kind
of rash and they were using patients
with celiac disease as their control
group but what they found was patients
with celiac disease
had
iga
iga-based antibodies that were
binding to the endomysium of monkey
esophagus so i'm showing a
a picture of that
there
and so that really revolutionized
serology testing for celiac disease
it took another couple decades
to discover that the antigen that was
binding to endomysium
uh is tissue transglutaminase so now
when we talk about ema we're really
talking about ttg tissue
transglutaminase by ifa
and then in the 90s that really burned
the commercial market into action and
they developed a series of different
elisa
based assays to measure ttg iga and also
ttg igg the newest test to the market
was about a decade ago
for deaminated glia and peptide and
we're still learning
more about this assay and how it can be
helpful helpful in the diagnosis now all
of this all this serology has also been
kind of
uh
parallel with the hla
testing for dq2 and dq8 alleles they
aren't really the focus
of this presentation but i'll just
highlight briefly that
it is a good test to rule out celiac
disease if you do not have either of
these alleles
it virtually excludes the possibility
for celiac disease
the current american college of
gastroenterology guidelines do not
consider
a serologic diagnosis for celiac disease
as of
2013 and there haven't been any updates
updates since then
these consensus guidelines state that if
the patient has sufficient iga then ttg
and or dgp
depending on the age should be measured
and if either of those results are
positive or if there is a high suspicion
regardless of the test result for
example even if they were negative then
the patient should proceed to biopsy for
confirmation
now there is some nuance in the less
than two years old age group
since we do know that their livers are
still developing which could result in a
low iga and there was worry that ttg iga
wouldn't be sensitive enough sensitive
enough in this population
and so dgp igg is recommended as a
paired test in this group
however there is more recent data that
suggests that ttg iga is still
sufficient
in these cases and that there isn't a
big
value add and including dgp igg
except
if you have very low iga or complete iga
deficiency
and then it should replace ttg iga
now in all of these cases testing should
be done on a gluten
containing diet
and in general the acg suggests
staying away from combining several
tests at one time just follow the simple
algorithm
for iga sufficient populations
and that
you shouldn't use native gliadin anymore
as i mentioned previously
and you should still proceed to biopsy
even
in the case of a negative serology if
there is high suspicion
for celiac disease
the discussion for a biopsy-free
diagnosis really began in europe with
the s began guidelines from 2012
recently updated in 2020
these guidelines
state that if your patient is
symptomatic and you have a ttg iga
greater than 10 times the upper limit of
normal
and you have a positive ema on a
separate collection
and you have a positive hla one or both
dq2 or dq8 alleles
then you can
consider
the celia diagnosing with celiac disease
without pursuing a biopsy confirmation
now if you have positive ttg but it's
less than 10 times the upper limit of
normal if you don't have a positive ema
then you should still proceed to biopsy
they updated
these guidelines in 2020
taking out the requirement that the
patient be symptomatic so in this case
you could screen
asymptomatic patients
and they also removed the requirement
for hla since that has been shown
not to add much in the in the diagnostic
value for celiac disease
the american gastroenterological
association aga recently published a
practice update
um which is heavily influenced by the s
began guidelines and i'll point out
written by the same lead author dr husby
this flow chart here um
is taken from the s began guidelines and
basically
basically is consistent
with ttg
iga greater than 10 times the upper
limit of normal and a positive ema and a
second blood sample is
considered confirmatory for celiac
disease now this is the first north
american
group to
put out this practice update acg like i
mentioned still has not
updated their guidelines and i don't
think there's uh consensus across
certainly our own gastroenterologists
um but also
throughout the countries canada and and
the united states
that this is the direction there's
there's still discussion
here
our gi practice interest in pursuing the
serological diagnosis
in specific patients coincided with our
method switch from an elisa based assay
to an automated
platform the bioplex 2200
this platform is a flow-based
immunoassay that uses
these bead kits
for assays so what that means is there
are these
small like eight micro micrometer beads
that have
unique antigens bound to them and
they're color coded
so that with their dual laser multiplex
flow detection method as the beads
flow through one laser identifies the
bead analyte and the second laser
measures the analyte concentration in
this way each b kit could
potentially measure multiple
analytes and for celiac disease kits
there are two one for ttg
and dgp iga so the iga based antibiotic
together and then another one for the
igg
based antibodies
this assay is fully automated and random
access
which is one of the reasons why our lab
converted
made the workflows a lot easier to
manage with this high volume assay
holding at all described a nice clinical
evaluation for the performance of the
bioplex 2200 celiac assays with a modest
sample size they demonstrated good
sensitivity
using a known celiac population and good
specificity using residual samples from
auto antibody screening as their control
population
this study also highlighted an important
feature that i forgot to mention about
the biplex assay which is its
iga deficiency detection bead so when
you measure ttg iga
using the beads there's a control bead
in there that
measures iga
as well and it will flag not give you a
result if iga
is not detected
and then this allows your lab to
set up a protocol for for when that
happens in our lab
we have a reflex
test that gets ordered
automatically when this flag is detected
that adds on an iga and reports a
comment um that ttg is unreliable uh
without
iga
the question remains can we
avoid biopsy in pediatric patients can
we apply a serological diagnosis
using
an upper limit of normal cut off
well the answer is it's complicated
there are few north american studies
that looked at this
the top plot here
shows
a multi-site study it's relatively small
that included 240 patients
over five different
sites health centers methodology was not
collected as part of the study so it
definitely demonstrates
real
life variation and practices
and what they found was even with it
upper limit
10 times upper limit of normal
cut off
the positive predictive value
was
not as good as
the europeans were describing in the
initial studies so 87.7
[Music]
and the specificity was quite low when
you would expect
um a higher specificity
when you're cut off is 10 times higher
another study out of calgary
this bottom table here
used used one assay had they had
definitely a bigger sample size a
thousand patients total
and they were using the euro immune
elisa
assay and they looked at different cut
off levels
overall and then also
excluding nodes that did not have a
positive ema and what they found was
that this
with this assay um there was relatively
good positive predictive value 95.9
percent and that positive predictive
value increased only modestly
[Applause]
if you required a positive ema
and the message
remains that we need local validation
for this 10 times the upper limit of
normal cutoff to account for population
differences as well as
variation and methodologies there's this
nike nice quote
from a paper that came out a few years
ago
regarding this
this cut off
saying that this inconsistency
in assays could lead to clinical
uncertainty unless individual
laboratories locally validate the tests
they decide to use this perspective is
supported by studies that have
demonstrated a wide variability of the
upper limit of normals when comparing
different commercially available
anti-ttg
assays
and so that is what we wanted to do
we put together a study in collaboration
with our
celiac clinic
that
looked at
retrospective
samples so we we pulled all ttg iga
samples from an 18 month time period
that included patients who had ttg iga
ordered and who also
received
a duodenal biopsy within six months of
that initial
ttg
so in this time period we have we
performed a total of 64 6 400
tgg igas on unique patients
567 of those patients also had a
duodenal biopsy within six months
and we ended up excluding 26 patients
for the following reasons
uh 16 because this was not their first
ttg iga they had an original
test performed at an outside lab
seven of these patients were iga
deficient and two had did not have
histology slides
available
for our study pathologist to review
that left us with 542
patients to analyze
84 of these patients were diagnosed with
celiac disease and 464 patients
had alternate diagnoses
as part of the study
my art my co-author and the study
pathologist dr pacheco
reviewed each pathology
slides again and independently
staged them
on the march staging scale
so i just want to take a second to talk
about
the what the biopsy process is like
so this this picture demonstrates um the
small intestine here that you the
duodenum uh is right after
um the stomach here it's this u-shaped
it's this u-shape
portion of the small intestine and then
the small intestine goes on here now
what's important is that within the
small intestine you normally have these
healthy finger like
called villi
and that is how
nutrients get absorbed
if you have celiac disease untreated
celiac disease these fingers these villi
are blunted
and and therefore they you lose quite a
bit of surface area and nutrients
um no longer can absorb
and that's why malabsorption is one of
the uh
one of the symptoms we try to
avoid
especially in pediatrics when treating
celiac disease
so
the gastroenterology will do an
endoscopy
and they'll insert a camera and a tube
down
with some forceps and what they're
supposed to do is take
five a minimum of five biopsy samples
it'll pinch off little bits of tissue
along the duodenum so this upper part of
the small intestine and at least one one
of those five should be from the bulb
and the bulb is what connects
to the stomach
and this is important taking enough
samples because celiac disease is known
to be with what is called apache disease
meaning that you may not you may miss it
if you're not looking at various parts
along along a duodenum
these slides
represent what marsh
scoring looks like
for the different stages and i just want
to thank christina pacheco our
pathologist
my colleague who provided these images
so you can see how in marsh zero you can
see the normal
villi how they're separated
the kind of bright pink areas those are
intra-epithelial lymphocytes and this is
marsh zero has
normal
march 1 you can start to see an increase
in intra-epithelial lymphocytes and then
all the way to marsh
3
you can see
atrophy or blunting of the villi
structures
as well as elongated
cellularity within the lamina propria
in our study which i'll show you the
results in a minute we didn't have any
patients who had march 3 which is good
because that is quite advanced
so these first results i want to share
are using the manufacturer cutoff so 15
units per milliliter
looking at sensitivity and specificity
for ttg iga
and so what you can see
uh
is the
marsh score
greater than 2 is considered positive
for celiac disease
and 15 or greater is considered
considered positive for the ttg iga test
and sensitivity
and specificity were both greater than
92 percent
the other numbers in these brackets here
i should point out these are biopsy
fragments that had
five or more taken
not every
biopsy
comes with the recommended number
of samples
and so we calculated sensitivity and
specificity for the total as well as for
those that had
the preferred amount of samples that
were taken
the negative predictive value
was great just so we would expect 97
and the positive predictive value is
about 72 percent
now using the 10 times upper limit of
normal as the cutoff
we found very high specificity for
celiac disease of 99.9
um
with a very good positive predictive
value of about 98
uh
basically only two
so you can see from the table i'll just
highlight for you
we had two positive
ten times upper limit of normal patients
that did not have a marsh score of two
or greater
so some considerations that i want to
highlight
for this study is one we did not include
ema or hla typing
in our calculations for sensitivity and
specificity and this is really due to
our institutional usage of these tests
we don't routinely test ema
at all it's not even a defined
test and the requests right now are
really are really limited to those um
to those patients where they are
considering a serologic diagnosis for
one reason or another
um the prevalence of celiac disease and
this relatively enhanced population was
15
and that and i want to point out again
that's why i think uh
the sensitivity and specificity of 92
percent that's really quite impressive
because this is a real
population of
patients who were being screened for
some re some reason enough that they
went on to
get a biopsy
so we would expect
to lose a little specificity you know
it's not a completely normal
population
so i think that's great and then with
the 10 times upper limit the specificity
is is quite high um the prevalence of
iga deficiency in our population we had
those seven that were excluded from the
study
was 1.3 percent
so the main takeaway here
is the biopsies that could be avoided
when implementing
a serologic diagnosis um
using a 10 times upper limit of normal
cut off so we had 44 patients that met
this criteria 42 of which
um
knowing you know having hindsight
in our hands we would know that we could
have made the diagnosis without a biopsy
two of these were technically
false positives both of them had marsh
one scoring so they weren't
marsh zeros they definitely had some
abnormal findings
and one of these false positives had was
a patient
with type 1 diabetes who was diagnosed
in the bath in the biopsy to have h
pylori gastritis
and this is
similar to other studies that have found
that h pylori gastritis can also cause
false positives the other false positive
i put in quotes had a marsh one lesion
but the patient was diagnosed with
celiac disease
due to their other symptoms and
resolution on a gluten-free
diet so
in our clinical practice
only one of these would have been
falsely diagnosed
and then i just want to also highlight
from this study and other studies from
our group
that patients with type 1 diabetes
should be considered separate from this
group undergoing consideration for
asymptomatic serologic diagnosis
because we just don't have enough
information on this group and we do know
they tend to have moderately elevated
ttg
but don't yet have symptoms of celiac
disease
and with that i would just like to
end with a quote from one of my kids
favorite shows odd squad
that couldn't do it without without our
team
and especially marci bhandari who
spent a lot of time organizing these
samples and the testing
in our lab so that we could we could put
this
together
and the the other
collaborators on this project are dr
dale lee and dr christina uh pacheco
thank you so much
thank you dr sefia chavelli and dr
dickerson for your informative
presentations we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
now let's get started
our first question
is are the u.s gastroenterology
consensus groups considering serological
diagnosis for celiac disease
hi this is um jane dickerson can you
hear me okay antonia
yes we can
okay perfect um
so i i did mention in the presentation
there's one
um one group the aga
that has revised their consensus
statements to include the
diagnosis
i haven't seen updates
from acg but i do know that our
gastroenterologists have
kind of been inching towards this
practice following
kind of a modified european
job guidelines
over the past couple of years and i
think i've seen that increase recently
due to some issues we've had internally
just with wait times to get
into the clinic for endoscopy
and you know families are not wanting
to wait months on a potentially harmful
diet
so they've been they've been using
using the ttg upper limit cut off
and the presence of ema
to support that
support that decision so i think it's
only a matter of time
um and we'll we'll just have to see
great thank you so much for that
um another question i have we which
quality assurance parameters are used in
the lab to monitor consistency of test
performance over time
um hi this is lucia can you hear me well
yes
so that's a great question actually for
auto antibody assays
it can be quite challenging to perform
quality assurance over time
so we use several strategies so we have
of course our
negative and positive control that was
done as part of every run
these are usually manufacturer based
controls and the limitation with those
is that they can be non-commutable so
usually they're purified samples they're
not
like real serum samples
so
some labs also choose to use external
controls this could be either serum
pools or it could be
purchased kind of a
serum based or serum matrix based
controls
additionally
we perform in the lab and
we're required through
various regulation bodies
when we get a new batch of reagent which
is considered a new lot of reagent to do
a lot to lot validation
and that helps ensure consistency as we
switch from one lot to another
and for this every lab practice can be
actually different in our lab we'll take
10 samples
across the range of the assay and we'll
compare them
to make sure that there's consistency um
and the criteria for acceptability could
be different depending on how
quantitatively consistent your assay is
anywhere from like 15 to 30 percent may
be considered acceptable in terms of the
difference um and another challenge with
other antibody assays is that we are
sometimes talking about
semi-quantitative assays so that can be
different from other immunoassays where
we'll see a precision of
five percent uh or extremely consistent
performance over a very long period of
time
and that's something that's important to
keep in mind that these assays are
semi-quantitative so we may see
more a bit more variability over time
and a higher imprecision than that
so hopefully that answers the question
perfect thank you so much
um another question for dr dickerson um
would her gis and her lab bring up ema
in-house in order to move to serological
diagnosis that ema is a component that
is that ema a component that must be
incorporated
um
hello again
so this
i might just say something a little bit
controversial so no we
we aren't going to bring ema in-house we
do send it out um to our primary
reference lab um in those cases where a
serologic diagnosis is being pursued
but i think that what our data shows and
where my my
preference is leaning is that ema
actually isn't um
isn't that useful um anymore it
i think it provides an additional layer
of confidence when you're going to make
a you know a lifelong diagnosis that
there are two tests
that support each other but we we did
our study in the absence of them ema
um and we've done other kind of internal
studies it rarely
uh surprises you when the when the ttg
is that um elevated
so i i don't know we will see
um you know what other studies come out
to to support that but i think
you know
it's
it's
uh
i'm not advocating for it it's long-term
it's long-term use at this point
all right thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question also for you dr dickerson what
is the role of hla testing in celiac if
no longer part of the algorithm for
serological diagnosis
yeah and i would be interested in
lucia's
perspective here too
for us you know we don't we don't um
it's not part of the algorithm we do
have it as a defined send out and i
think there is a place
um
for this type of
screening when you want to permanently
rule out
celiac disease the best case it would be
useful for is in those autoimmune
conditions where we know that
celiac disease is at risk
for example
trisomy 21
or type 1 diabetes
but in those cases they actually also
have there's been lot there's been
several studies showing that that
positive hla is prevalent in those
populations as well so it doesn't
really help as much
as we'd want it to in terms of a rule
out test
uh but you know there are certainly
specific scenarios that i can imagine it
would be helpful to know it's
definitively not celiac disease and they
can take it off their um
their uh long-term algorithm
uh lucia what do you think i agree with
you jane i think i don't directly
oversee hla dq2 chladq-2n8 genotyping so
it is a send out for us as well so i can
only comment from
the discussions um
that i've had with our gi or celiac
clinic physicians
and the practice actually has changed
over time previously um hla dq 2 and 8
were were more frequently utilized and
also in those risk groups
genotyping it's my understanding it was
a more routine practice
but with the emergence of the more
recent guidelines
using serologic testing as a kind of a
first tier test
i think
they each the genotyping is becoming
less prevalent it is helpful i think in
certain cases like ruling out and
difficult to diagnose cases um i think
there's still some utility there but i
think it is the demand for it is
decreasing in light of the guidelines
that are emerging and the evidence
that's coming up
perfect
thank you dr stephanie schwelli and dr
dickerson do you have any final comments
for our audience
um no but i i think i can say that feel
free to email me if you have further
questions my email is on the slide deck
and i'm happy to take comments as well
thank you for attending
thank you
thank you
there is a comment here i think i just
saw one come through
um someone from the university of
arkansas for medical sciences sharing
their practice
that they use hla testing successfully
to screen for susceptibility and lack of
susceptibility
thank you for that comment from the
audience member and thank you again both
so much for your time today and your
important research we'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor sponsor
biorad laboratories for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitting
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
thank you so much until next time
goodbye